pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
un beau coup de chiffon indispensable
pour les bulles mais d'où sortent tél ça
donne envie de s'y plonger un pas dans
le champagne dans les bulles un peu
d'histoire de petites histoires
selon la légende la méthode
d'élaboration du champagne aurait été
mise au point à la fin du xviie siècle
par un moine don pérignon à l'abbaye
saint pierre d'hautvillers aujourd'hui
située dans le département de la marne
près de reims
pour être tout à fait honnête la recette
n'est pas totalement sorti de son
cerveau il se serait inspiré d'une
méthode élaborée initialement dans le
sud de la france dans la région de
limoux près de perpignan à seule
donnerait au prochain dîner c'est sûr je
me faire mousser les bulles du champagne
viennent du gaz carbonique le co2
contenu dans le vin c'est le même gaz
qu'on injecte en grande quantité dans
les canettes de soda fait que ces
boissons soit pétillante dans le
champagne le co2 n'est pas injecter il
se développe naturellement dans le vin
et je vais vous montrer offert du
champagne
il faut du raisin traditionnellement les
vignerons champenois utilise trois
cépages trois variétés du chardonnay du
pinot noir et du pinot meunier cette
assemblée le raisin est pressé on
récupère le jus qu'on appelle le mouton
laisse fermenter dans de grandes cuves
comme celle ci le sucre présent dans la
pulpe du raisin se transforment en
alcool et en gaz carbonique qui
s'échappe librement étant donné que ces
cuves ne sont pas fermés hermétiquement
d'ailleurs ça se sent un peu jusque là
le processus est exactement le même pour
tous les vins qu'il soit blanc ou rouge
qu'on appelle
des vins tranquilles non
pas
ces caves ont été creusés il y a huit
cents ans pour construire la ville de
château-thierry
on va peut-être activer un peu parce que
là je ne sais toujours pas d'où sortent
les bulles
je viens
[Musique]
pour le champagne la suite de l'histoire
est différente au lieu de vieillir en
fut le champagne est mis en bouteille
à ce stade on ajoute du sucre et des
levures commence alors -la deuxième
fermentation alcoolique
les levures transforment le sucre en gaz
carbonique un gaz carbonique qui ne peut
pas s'échapper cette fois puisque la
bouteille est fermé c'est ce qu'on
appelle la prise de mousse le champagne
qui jusque là était un vin tranquille se
transforme en vin effervescent
naturellement chargée en gaz carbonique
[Musique]
on se réveille
oh excusez moi j'étais dans ma bulle
j'observais le dépôt qui se forme durant
cette étape et bleu du champagne elles
ne sont pas visibles pour qu'elles se
forme il faut déboucher une bouteille
les bulles ne se voit pas parce que le
gaz est dissout une bouteille comme
celle ci contient 75 centilitres de
liquides et du gaz du gaz qui lorsqu'ils
se retrouvent à la pression
atmosphérique occupent un volume 6 fois
plus grand que cette bouteille
autrement dit cette bouteille de 75
centilitres piège 5 litres de gaz 5
litres qui se retrouve sous pression à
l'intérieur de la bouteille
vous comprenez maintenant pourquoi le
verre des bouteilles de champagne est si
épais pour résister à la pression qui
règne à l'intérieur cinq à six fois la
pression atmosphérique
vous vous donner une idée c'est la
pression qui règne à 50 60 mètres de
profondeur dans l'océan
[Musique]
au passage voilà à quoi ressemble au
départ le bouchon qui va remplacer la
capsule
une fois qu'on a évacué le dépôt il est
beaucoup plus large qu'un bouchon
classique pas vrai mon p'tit bouchon
il est enfoncé deux forces dans le
goulot mais le frottement du liège
contre la paroi n'est pas suffisant pour
résister à la pression il faut rajouter
ce que l'on appelle un musée très utile
également au moment où on débouche la
bouteille attention il faut bien le
retenir car avec la pression le bouchon
peut être éjecté à plus de 60 kilomètres
par heure
les voilà enfin les petites bulles
maintenant que la bouteille est ouverte
et que la pression a brutalement chuté
le gaz carbonique cherche à se détendre
et à s'échapper mais pour cela pour se
détendre
il lui faut de l'espace et bien ils le
trouvent dans le vert plus précisément
sur les poussières qui sont collés au
fond et sur les parois d'où l'intérêt de
donner un coup de torchon avant de
servir le champagne poussières
atmosphériques fibre déposée par le
torchon grossi des milliers de fois
voilà à quoi ressemblent ces poussières
la surface très irrégulière comme vous
pouvez le constater et belges des
petites bulles d'air le co2 va s'y
glisser et se détendre il y prend sa
forme gazeuse quand la bulle est assez
volumineuse
elle se détache et s'élève comme une
montgolfière
merci les petits pneus puis une autre
bulle se forme etc etc
en montant les bulles de champagne se
charge encore plus de gaz carbonique
elles prennent du volume et se charge
aussi de molécules aromatiques parvenu
en surface
elle éclate et pourquoi les chaussures
de sport parce que l éclatement des
bulles projette des microgouttelettes à
la vitesse de 15 mètres par seconde un
tout petit peu plus vite que la vitesse
du cndd bolt le champion jamaïcain au
son maître une poussière peut donner
naissance à une quinzaine de bulles
on a compté un verre comme celui ci peut
produire jusqu'à 1 millions de bulles un
deuxième temps si c'est une liste aux
côtés de cette espèce d'embrun
comparable à celui qui se forment au
dessus des vagues de l'océan permet de
sentir les arômes du vin
quand on approche le vert de son nez et
cela avant même qu'on ait le champagne
en bouche une dernière chose
[Musique]
flûte ou coupent dans une flûte le
champagne petty plus longtemps la
colonne de bull et plus haute est la
surface de contact avec l'extérieur est
beaucoup moins grande que dans une coupe
surtout pas de gobelets même en carton
la surface intérieure de ces derniers
est recouverte d'une pellicule plastique
pour les rendre étanches
le problème c'est que les bulles
adhèrent à ce matériau bon bah on va
pouvoir déguster 909 900 1 million ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle poussé le bouchon
un peu loin
n'oubliez pas le champagne c'est à
consommer avec modération quant aux
vidéos vous pouvez vous resservir autant
que vous voulez aller
joyeux noël et à très bientôt mais mince
alors c'est pas possible
possible d'en arrêter tout de suite je
rêve ou quoi
[Musique]